your characters kind of a kleptomaniac
yes I steal a camera and some chocolate
stealing the camera for John was the
only thing he could do in order to have
that camera we see him walk up to a
camera store earlier and and then we see
him retrieve a broken television set and
in that moment he's just kind of
explained to this other character how
he's felt trapped in his life he's
dealing with blocks of directions and in
this moment of watching this group of
people do this improvisational dance in
this part you know in North Side of New
York he sees an opportunity for
something that he's interested in and
it's one of the times that he steps out
of himself and he takes it and I think
for the candy bar he's hungry and he
wants some chocolate and it's a it's
it's it's it's one of those things that
you know I don't know he likes there's a
part of him that likes to steal and
there's a pleasure in it I think the
burst the burst of that yeah there's a
little bit of a nuance to it character
for that I mean we had some fun about
like how are you gonna steal that candy
bar yeah and markers like I'm going to
introduce you to this addition he's a
petty criminal
my question to you Mike what do you
think what was the thinking beyond that
when you were writing a character um you
know I was just thinking about how how
how do you change your life you know and
it's just like often times I think that
you have to you have to make a bold move
and you have to do something that people
don't necessarily congratulate you for -
to give yourself what you need to move
forward and you know I mean that kind of
it you know you speak metaphorically
it's just it's it's it's kind of the way
things have gone we haven't you know
we've sort of entered into sort of a
time where where that kind of thing is
sort of seen as the only way that you
can actually get ahead and you know for
better for us it's entered into our
sense of right and wrong that concerns
about us it's a complication I mean also
pace for the coffee and you know it's
all there's a visit there's a management
of wrongdoing I mean you know in the
whole movie he's doing some you know
John is also enabling you know there's a
nurturing its nurturing versus enabling
there's every single scene in the movie
has has a yes and a no so it's it's but
in the context of what he is his job is
stealing a candy bar it's it's a it's a
consistency of character their roles
through the whole movie
being a character of such few words
you're forced to you know rely on what
your remoting what was the biggest
challenge with that because I mean you
have to emot-- the various layers yeah
you know it's a wonderful opportunity
you know I would say the the scariest
scene was the scene where John and
violet come together because playing
John I had no idea how that could
actually happen
idea like how how could this person who
felt so vulnerable and insular and who
wanted to reach out and had so many
questions and how can also how could he
help someone really you know feeling
loved you know just how was that going
to heaven and a lot of film rolled on
maybe ever all together it was the
hardest seeing the movie to cut it was
the last piece it was finding that level
of intimacy was just do you feel every
filmmaker should also be editor I'm
curious why you used the camera as a
catalyst for change I found it very
interesting is that from being a
documentarian I think I mean you know I
guess I made films on some of about what
I know and and and you know I made two
now they're there they're both filmmaker
films they're about the filmmaking
process on some level and because that's
what I it's been my life it's my thing
it's sort of a documentary about the
narrative filmmaking process a narrative
editing process and the second movie is
a narrative that sort of incorporates a
man
learning how to use a camera in a
documentary sort of the way
it's you know there's elements of that I
was just gonna because we talked to the
two lead actresses earlier and there's
talking a lot about how great the
rehearsal process was like getting to
know you and how trying to get your
attention and figuring out how to work
certain scenes could you just elaborate
on the whole like the rehearsal and the
improvisation in general especially when
it came to having the camcorder in the
picture yeah there was no improvisation
in the sense of dialogue in any movie
until the end the credit scene but then
there was like you know how are we gonna
do these scenes which we kind of worked
out Mark was really collaborative and
really downloaded everybody about
sharing his perspective and then what
was your perspective and you know your
character and and and and then you know
when we got together we found that we
were all so fond of the piece and so
that there was a real kind of we even
almost sometimes talked about it in
third person you know like okay isn't
this great where John and violet or
coming again with me yeah they love the
way that this it deals with intimacy and
then lies and in the levels of and then
we would kind of get into it and and and
there was a real camaraderie you know
with us I remember you know he was mark
Astor we've got on the street take some
pictures and then you know do his
project and then you know Adelaide and
all Jana and I went out to a bar in two
pictures that are on the rage in the
movie and a photobooth and stuff so
there was a lot of life and art kind of
coming together which when you're making
a film that's one of the coolest things
is when you're you know our artists are
coming together of like mind and
and about the work and general mark
really kind of you know foster best when
you start to inject hope optimism and
low inside a wrapper of dissociation and
alienation well so that the sense of
your character and the same with the
Sarita chattery that they're both they
listen like you just you don't kind of
assault the world with noise which I get
really felt from the film you know and I
was wondering is that a combat
I mean it's called generation on is that
how it works I mean is this what we're
becoming we just talk at each other and
no one really listens and so I'm sorry
father just you listen to them you've
let them kind of tell their story is
that what we need is that kind of the
message of the film versus read each
other she is great yeah but yes it's
quite understanding that's going on
behind their energy was you enjoy
working with actors Keanu and Sarita in
that particular scene as they were so
connected but they were not even looking
at each other
but yet the answer to the question is
yes that is that is that is definitely a
piece of it it's there's there's a you
know we're just we're becoming immune to
anything into everything and it's it's
just you know nothing is shocking
anymore and so we there's a state of
shock yeah maybe I think you know these
characters have our shocked characters
in life you know in transformation and
trying to change to reach out to have a
kind of intimacy to to have a kind of
connection it's an interesting blend of
perceptions on things when they're
different like when writing a script and
portraying a character that's written in
a script and it fascinates me the the
subtle differences in motivation also
like whatever my intention in writing it
and your intention and playing that
character they are different and we
could we can talk about it it's a it's a
really fun conversation yeah but yeah I
just like the design electic is yeah
it's so low in communal yes yes personal
and inherited its conflict and
collaboration yeah and here we are just
curious what each of you at the end of
this process looking back appreciated
most or took away most from working with
the other
if she didn't even know one thing you
know I appreciated just you know working
with Canada I mean it's my first
narrative film and I feel very honored
to have been able to make the film I
wanted to make without really any
restriction you know like we got the we
got to let it be organically what it was
and a big part of that is his influence
and and I appreciate that because I was
allowed to just make the film and
without which I've heard stories about
I've just been very lucky you know
working with all of them it's you know
just the patience in the end they like
to just the honesty and that everyone
work really hard and they they walking
into a room with a bunch of people that
you really respect and having them love
your work right there in the room is
like nothing I can't even describe it
it's I mean wow it's the script and they
they did they they put love into it and
I was just like bows good piece of bread
and I would say that you know I would
say that the opportunities there are so
many pleasures that mark story offered
me as an actor and also just something
to my taste you know this this idea of
hope you know
trapped characters and also the way that
he was trying to tell the story in a
non-traditional way you know not
reinventing the wheel but paying homage
to a lot of levels cinematically and
could
and also respect to the audience and for
these characters to play did letting me
you know shoot scenes and to be creative
in that way so I would say the
opportunity to be creative where did the
idea for New York City chasey come from
involving whoo whooping Cowboys
Wow that question is you know I'm not
even sure the answer that question came
out it came it came out of it was
originally something different and
something could not be done and so in
the end of it it became about how to get
the action of the movie from one point
to the next movie to the next part of
the film it is the transition it came
from wandering through New York and and
having just odd experiences happen all
around me you know it it came from
involving like a hundred extras or a
hundred like however many people in a
little tiny film there certain things
just happen and it just sort of grows of
its own accord you know it it came from
wanting to jump a turnstile in the New
York City Subway you know it came to
wanting to shoot on the subway as a
filmmaker you know it came from it came
from wanting to do something absurd and
to tip a hat to french absurdist
filmmaking and and like the million
other things that came from that that
the parking lot was shot and there's a
flea market that I've been passing by
for 15 years it came from wanting to
shoot in that parking lot and it came
from wanting to see John being chased
down the street but you know a horde of
and looking at the smile on his face
you know thank you so much thank you so
much